I'm gonna very carefully wade into the
topic of breastfeeding again you might
remember that the last time I mentioned
breastfeeding on the show as many years
ago it ended up with multiple Facebook
groups from groups like the leaky boob
and lacta vist unite demanding an
apology from me so I'm gonna try to
avoid that today because I do need to
talk about breastfeeding again there was
going to be a UN resolution to encourage
breastfeeding it appeared to be
completely uncontroversial the research
is pretty clear the mother is able to
breastfeed breastfeeding as healthiest
for children there should be an effort
made globally to encourage responsible
safe breastfeeding when the mother is
able and there should also be an effort
to limit the misinformation or the
disinformation that is out there about
breastfeeding simple no big deal for
some reason as this was being negotiated
the United States delegation to the
United Nations affiliated World Health
Assembly seem to be opposed to the
resolution which was very confusing to a
lot of people American officials wanted
to change the resolution they wanted to
weaken the resolution they wanted to
remove language that called for
governments to protect promote and
support breastfeeding in another section
which called on politicians to restrict
promoting food products that can be
negative for children according to the
medical community the you the United
States delegation wanted that removed
other countries fortunately said no we
want to keep that stuff in there so the
American officials started issuing
threats for example to Ecuador saying
hey Ecuador if you don't drop this we
might punish you with trade policy and
of the removal of military aid over
breastfeeding and it actually worked on
Ecuador Ecuador needed the money and
they acquiesced eventually Russia
stepped in and said we're gonna
introduce the resolution and push it
forward and that finally did get the
United States to back down and stop
opposition to it why on earth was the
United States opposed to this the State
Department was asked they declined to
comment they said oh that relates to
private diplomatic conversations can't
talk about that the Department of Health
and Human Services said well we were
involved in it but we weren't involved
the threatening ecuador part so you're
gonna have to talk to somebody else
about that and there was the idea brooch
which is not an unreasonable idea that
the formula lobby and the baby food
industry went to the meeting which they
did we know that some of them were at
the meeting and they pushed for the
united states to oppose this but right
now we at least don't have specific
evidence that the the lobbies were able
to play a role in getting the u.s. to
interfere but clearly something is very
wrong here because this is an
administration that seems opposed to
breastfeeding during the negotiations
the u.s. threatened to pull funding from
the World Health Organization and I
don't think this is actually an
anti-science thing I think it's merely
pro-corporate like we've talked about
how Trump has spouted some anti-vaxxer
propaganda or seems to have been taken
in by it I don't think that's actually
what's going on here at all I think it's
a corporate I think it's pro corporate
to because that sounds like the only
reasonable explanation - right and maybe
it's because this isn't such a major
issue he thought that we could just
sweep this under the rug no one would
really pay attention to it because it's
not like it's a campaign issue it's not
a meeting is not a campaign issue you
know although Trump it's called the
reports about this fake news he said
something like we're not we're not
against breastfeeding but we just don't
want like misinformation about good
products like formula or something like
that which is a way of kind of reframing
a very Pro corporate position to sound
like it's actually about health and I
think the bottom line here is that even
though corporate meddling hasn't been
proven it seems like it's part of the
very pro corporate bias of the Trump
administration on everything right on
public health on environmental issues
that's what seems to be the trend here
this pro corporate bias and as far as
the breastfeeding thing we've got
decades of data on breastfeeding we have
that that part is not actually
controversial and the United States
delegation decided that for whatever
reason they were going to hold the world
hostage when it comes to breastfeeding I
I don't like using this term but this is
a really weird Hill to die on yeah I
want to keep abreast of this situation I
think what you find out more about it we
are increasingly becoming the impediment
that the world community has to
circumvent to
keep moving forward and that's not
really a great position for the United
States to be in